[Music]
coming to you from his house in Los
Angeles it's Conan he's broken
I'm Andy Richter tonight sophie Turner
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there Conan O'Brien here and I just
learned that my stool can swivel which
is exciting that's a big step up from
yesterday this is day two Tuesday we had
a lot of fun last night with Adam
Sandler and tonight on Conan from home
broadcast from my home in Los Angeles
we'll be bringing you sophie Turner
I love sophie Turner sorry I shouldn't
have it made the camera jiggle very
excited to have her on the program and
as you can tell I am projecting with my
denim jacket a sense of calm but casual
Authority I'm also having trouble
finding the lens but I think it's yeah
there it is right there
anywho like the rest of you I seek out
friendships companionship during these
times and for me that means my good pal
of many many years Andy Richter so hey
Andy how are you I'm just happy to be
talking to somebody those headphones is
that you can we are you listening to
music while I try and talk to you Oh
Conan music is oh wait yeah it's
actually your podcast here's what I'm
having difficulty with I I can kind of
tell what day it is because we have to
make this show but other than that
without that to hang on to I would have
no idea what day it is I I have to see
if the price is right is on in order to
know that it's a weekday wait so the
price is right is telling you that it's
a weekday but it's yes but it doesn't
tell you which day it is well I mean I'm
not gonna get that specific I just need
to know it's a weekday so that means I
should put on pants
weekends are pants free I mean come on
isn't this the same technique you use
even when there isn't a pandemic that's
right Andy there are a lot of helpful
PSAs out there right now on how to
handle this current coronavirus crisis
and I decided that I would take my own
hey a lot of people are talking about
social distancing these days but what's
the right amount of distance people say
someone needs to be over six feet away
from you but how much is that when
you're on the fly how do you calculate
it I'm gonna tell you an easy solution
do what I do
grab your life-size cutout of former FBI
director James Comey he is famously six
feet eight inches tall
lay it down between you and the next
person and then you have it
I am safely distant I am one James Comey
away from the next person now
what if you don't have a James comb well
take your Kevin Hart now remember if
someone is one Kevin Hart away from you
that means they're too close way too
close so take your backup Kevin Hart now
someone is - Kevin Hart's away from me
still not enough you need three Kevin
Hart's three Kevin Hart's distance and
just to be really safe four
for Kevin Hartz between you and the next
person and you are perfectly safe there
you go problem solved let's get dinner
[Music]